hello everyone welcome to today's
presentation entitled population scale
human genome analysis on the cloud my
name is Peter white I'm director of the
biomedical genomic score here at
Nationwide Children's Hospital in
Columbus Ohio and also an assistant
professor of pediatrics at the ohio
state university and i'll be speaking
today with james hürmüz whose CEO genome
next our presentation today will be in
two parts and we'll be discussing the
work that we did clarity collaboratively
with my team here at Nationwide
Children's and the team at genome next
but before we begin I just have a couple
of announcements this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them into the QA box which can be
found by clicking on the green QA button
at the lower left of the presentation
window we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of a
slide window and if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem for the green QA button on the
lower left finally I do want to thank
lab roots for their work in putting this
conference together and especially we
want to thank Intel for sponsoring this
presentation and so with that I'll go
ahead and get started
so the Human Genome Project term began
in 1991 and was an international effort
to sequence the first human genome and
it took an estimated fifteen years to
complete with a cost of about three
billion dollars so that's a dollar for
each base pair in the human genome if
you want to get an idea of what it would
look like if we were to print the human
genome this is a these photographs are
taken from the first printed copy of the
human genome was housed in the wellcome
collection in london and as you can see
on this bookcase it contains over 100
volumes with just each volume contains
that all of these pages with a C's GS
and T's and the three billion characters
that go to make up the genome so
fortunately today we're able to sequence
a genome a lot faster and you don't need
an international consortium of
scientists to sequence these are two of
the sequences that we have in my lab
here in the research institute at
Nationwide Children's the smaller
machine on your right is the aluminum my
seat this is a instrument that we use
for bacterial genome sequencing and for
smaller sequencing studies but our main
workhorse over the last four years been
the alumina hi seek instrument this is
capable of generating three billion
sequencing reactions in parallel roughly
producing about 1.2 terabytes of raw
data in a run and this allows us to
sequence a human genome in as little as
14 hours so a focus of my research has
been on dealing with all the enormous
amounts of data this instrument has been
generating with sequence thousands of
samples we have servers with trillions
of base pairs of data and so the
research of my group has been in an area
called translational bioinformatics
where we try to take this data and turn
it into something meaningful in terms of
molecular diagnostics clinical
treatments and clinical outcomes now it
would be nice if the output from these
sequences actually look like what we see
on the bookcase here but it doesn't the
sequences are
able to sequence the genome in small
fragments we go for a process in the lab
where we share the genome down to about
300 base paired fragments and then we're
able to generate anywhere from around
100 to 150 base pair reads from each end
of that fragment so it's a bit much like
if we were to take this entire
collection and run it through a paper
shredder getting output like this and
when we first started using this
sequencer I think this was our reaction
to the volumes of data that were coming
off of it because what we needed to do
is go for a complex analysis process of
taking all of this output and
reassembling it and to get back to this
original image and in the case of
pediatric pediatrics we were often
sequencing kids with rare genetic
disorders what we're looking for is the
one page in this entire collection that
contains a typo where is that one one
variant with in a gene that could be
causing a disease and here you can see
in red we have a see that's actually on
this page at E and so this is what this
is what the process that we're doing in
terms of analysis is going from that raw
output to finding this potentially
pathogenic barium so to do that there's
a number of steps in the analysis
workflow and it starts on the instrument
itself the sequencing process generates
these images that look like this star
cluster at the top of the screen there
and the first phase of analysis we call
primary analysis this is really taking
those images and turning them into
intensities and base calls subsequent to
primary analysis once we have those
baseballs you can begin the process of
secondary analysis and this is where we
go for a number of steps to actually
determine what what given variants a
patient may have and then finally
tertiary analysis is the more advanced
bioinformatics actually interpreting
what those genetic variants errands are
but for a long time the bottleneck has
been in this area of secondary analysis
going from that raw data to a list of
genetic variants so the process to do
secondary analysis is incomplete em
encompasses these five steps that I'm
showing here it begins with the raw
put from the instrument which is in fast
Q format and that has to go through a
process of alignment back to the
reference genome then there's a stage of
its called a local realignment that
corrects for alignment errors that may
be associated with small insertions and
deletions in the sequence then we remove
any duplicate reads that were introduced
during the laboratory phase of lively
preparation prior to sequencing and the
next step is to recalibrate the quality
schools that are associated with each
base and that allows us to more
accurately perform the final phase which
is variant calling and genotyping the
final output of this process is what we
call a variant cool format file or a VCF
file and this contains all of the
variants for a given sample and fro Hawk
human genome that's typically in the
order of about 4 million 4 million
genetic variants so the problem that we
run into when we first started doing
this was that we had an instrument that
was able to sequence a human genome and
as I said about just under two days 40
hours but it was taking us two weeks to
do the data analysis and our solution to
that was this and to come up with a new
way of performing the analysis by
carefully dis bikin carefully examining
each of these steps we optimize the
process by which the analysis could be
distributed across multiple computers
and and CN CPUs within a given computer
if you were in John Quackenbush his
session earlier today and he said that
my imitations like to name their
software after Hugh animals and he was
describing an algorithm called Panda we
named our our in Churchill and I guess
looking at Churchill there is not such a
few animal he's certainly a name that
must help people remember sticks in
people's mind when they hear the name of
the algorithm so I'm not going to go
into the great details about how we did
the processing of each of these steps
but it is described in full detail in a
publication that came out earlier this
year in genome biology
that's open an open-access article that
you can easily download and so when we
look at this process of doing the
secondary analysis there's a couple of
different approaches that can be taken
to paralyzation and one approach was to
paralyzed by chromosome as I'm showing
in this slide there's a limitation to
that approach it's a natural way that
genome can be divided up we have the 22
autosomes and the two sex chromosomes
here so in total we've got 24
chromosomes but the analysis process
could be / but there's two limitations
the first is that you're limited to 24
if you want to scale beyond 24 you can't
because that's the total number of
chromosomes that are available the
second limitation is that of chromosomal
Saleh's you'll see that chromosomes
different size chromosome one being the
largest is about 250 mega bases and
chromosome 21 being with smallest is
around 50 mega bases so any analysis
that's paralyzed by chromosome will be
limited by the size of the largest
chromosome chromosome 21 will finish
first and chromosomal one will be the
last last complete analysis so what we
did with churchill's we came up with a
strategy to balance the parallelization
by dividing the genome into sub
chromosomal regions and what this is
showing you here is this balance by
dividing the genome up across here in
this example it's 24 CPU usage in the
analysis you can see that each processor
is processing the same amount of data
and thereby the analysis has become
balanced and more efficient and that's
what we observed the when we compared
the paralyzation strategy utilized by
Churchill with that with two other
pipelines a part line called huge seek
and that's developed by Stanford that
uses chromosomal paralyzation and then
pipeline from the bro dance troupe
called gatk queue that uses scatter
counter paralyzation and what these
plots show you our utilization of CPU
for a single set for a single server
going from nought to 100 percent and
what you can see is the church
or have the highest utilization at about
ninety two percent followed by huge seek
forty-six percent and geo tkq thirty
percent so the other advantage of that
our approach was there and also one one
thing I want to point out here is that
you'll see that the chromosomal
paralyzation approaches by huge seek the
utilization product closely matches that
of the size distribution of the
chromosomes so what's happening is
chromosome one is taking the longest and
whereas the smaller chromosomes finish
first your resource utilization declines
closely matching that pattern so what we
observed with the result of balance
paralyzation strategy utilized by
Churchill was that it was highly
scalable so this plot shows you the
amount of speed up you get in terms of
the analysis time as you increase the
number of CPUs and what we observed is
the both huge seeking dat cake you
really didn't scale well beyond 48 cause
we're as Churchill scaled continue to
speed up as we used more cause for the
analysis and we did a computational
prediction using Andals Laurel and what
the theoretical maximum speed up you
could get we observe that showed
Churchill tracked closely with that
predicted by handles law the result is
that we could drastically reduce that
timeframe down from that two weeks down
to under two hours to do the analysis
what I'm showing you here from on our
in-house server with up to 192 cause
we're able to reduce the analysis time
down to just under five hours and then
when we run a larger on a larger cluster
at the Ohio supercomputing center with
768 cause we reduce the time down to
just under 100 minutes it's recent work
in my group we've been able to using
Amazon Web Services being able to reduce
this time frame down to 77 minutes and
one of our goal is to get this to under
an hour in the next few months but we
work in a pediatric Institute that's
currently using
chaloo genome next clinically and one of
our goals was not only to increase the
speed of analysis because that can be a
matter of life and death for kids with
rare pediatric diseases but we wanted to
ensure that we didn't make any
sacrifices to the quality of the data
and using the national institute of
standards and technologies genomes in a
bottle sample sample that was a
reference that was released last year we
were able to see across the board church
will have the highest rates in terms of
validation known variants it had the
highest accuracy in the lowest error
rate the in terms of the overall
diagnostic effectiveness which is
measured by the unit index which is the
sum of sensitivity and specificity minus
one we were seeing data at ninety nine
point six six percent again the highest
diagnostic effectiveness but the other
advantage of our approach for
paralyzation is that it's a one hundred
percent reproducible every time you run
the analysis we get the same results and
it's also deterministic and what I mean
by that is regardless of the computer
system the analysis is run on or
regardless of the level of
parallelization if you're using 24
chromosomal sub-regional you're using a
thousand chromosomal sub-regions you get
the same results the final PCF will be
the same and we believe is the only
pipeline that's able to make that claim
of both reproducibility and determinism
so how does this relate to population
scale genomics well one of the things
that we realized while Churchill was
very fast for an individual sample we
believe they could scale effectively to
do much larger scales on their studies
using thousands of samples and why this
is relevant is and this is a picture of
our sequencer in the lab but currently
can sequence if we run it 24 7
back-to-back would you do it most 150
genomes per year and the cost that would
be pretty prohibitive at about five
thousand genomes but five thousand
dollars per genome but alumina announced
last year new technology that would in a
population scale genomic sequencing this
is a photograph of the high cgx
instrument let's able to sequence up to
eighteen thousand genomes per year at a
cost appropriate thousand-dollar
thousand dollars per thousand dollars
per genome and generating enormous
volumes of data or 1.8 petabytes and
what we're seeing is that there are a
number of studies occurring around
around the globe to see where nations
are sequencing their populations and
this is a photograph of the cover of
this month's Nature Genetics where
decode genetics in Iceland published the
results of a study of a hundred thousand
Icelanders in my home country in the
United Kingdom genomics England is a
study funded by the National Health
Service that plans to sequence 100,000
patients and 100,000 patients and then
also the Saudi Saudi human genome
program again toggling to sequence a
hundred 100,000 Saudi genomes and then
the Pharaoh genome project is the Faroe
Islands plan to sequence their entire
nation I was about 50 50,000 50,000
people so we're starting to see
population scale studies beginning so
what we did last year is we proposed a
proof-of-concept study to Intel through
the something that was called the Intel
head in the clouds challenge on amazon
web services and what they get is they
solicited ideas from groups that wanted
to use these servers on amazon on an
honor on AWS the powered by Intel
processors to do it to do an analysis
that was a large scale so long with our
partners do you know next we propose to
study when we do analysis of the
thousand genomes data which is one of
the largest publicly available data sets
what the thousand genomes project is it
began in 2008 and we've been the work of
a international consortium of over 400
scientists to create the first deep
catalog of human genetic variation and
in october two thousand one phase one
was completed and the group released and
the population bearing frequencies for
92 individuals and then in april 2013
the group announced that a completed
their sequencing phase and then 18
months later in September 2014 the final
bearing calls and population frequencies
were were released and this was for a
total of two thousand five hundred and
four individuals across the 26
populations that I'm showing in the map
below now the great thing about the work
that the thousand genomes consortium has
done is they've made all of this data
publicly available all of the raw
sequencing data is stored on on Amazon's
S&ED stored in an Amazon s3 bucket
enabling groups to access it and do
their own analysis so the first thing we
needed to determine was to show the
Churchill would work on AWS and so again
this is showing you a resource
utilization plots of us what I showed
you earlier and we're seeing that we get
had highly efficient utilization of a
single work this is a single ec2
instance enabling us to complete
analysis of a 30x human genome in about
11 hours then as we increase the number
of instances the graph on the right
shows you how we're able to reduce that
time frame down to under under two hours
by the time we get to 16 instances and
in this case the we actually used in
more computationally intensive algorithm
to do the analysis that was recently
developed by the road institute called
gatk haplotype caller and using using
the churchill polarization approach
we're able to perform whole genome
haplotype calling in about 24 minutes so
given the we could show that work for a
single sample we then went about
designing how we would do this analysis
for the thousand genomes data set now as
I said it's all stored on Amazon in an
Amazon s3 bucket all 2504 individuals
were sequence with two different men
there are two different methods whole
genome sequencing and whole exome
sequencing so we actually had in total
5,000 may in
data sets were able to paralyze the
analysis of that using Churchill to
paralyze that through the fast q tube
and step doing alignment deduplication
indoor realignment and recalibration and
the final output of that was for each
genome we do each sample we divided them
into 512 genomic sub legions this gave
us a total of 2.6 million parallel
processes during this phase now in the
second step was to take these band files
these process band files through the
process of genotype genotyping then we
did this using a format called at GPC f
or genomic VCF genotyping and so for
each sample across the 512 regions were
able to do Aaron calling in parallel
again about 1.3 million parallel
processes during this phase the output
of this was each sample had AG VCF file
and that was divided into these 512 512
sub-regions per individual the final
step was to take these g VCF files and
do joint variant calling on them so for
each region we could take all 2504
individuals and perform the variant
calling that would ultimately produce
the population allele frequencies across
all across all of us up across all of
the samples so we were able to do this
from fast q2 those final population
frequencies in seven days and what we
found is that we had a very high level
of overlap with me variants that were
called by the thousand genomes
consortium as shown by the top end
diagram and but we did observe that we
discovered about 5.6 million novel
windows that were not caught by the
thousand genomes consortium and we
believe this may be that we used
potentially we used a more sensitive
approach to do the genotyping by using
this GV CF GP CF format along with
haplotype caller hallo cycle along with
homicide corner
but we did see is that for the variants
that we called in common there was an
extremely high level of correlation in
terms of the frequencies that they
report it and then the frequencies the
frequencies that we observed so to
summarize this part of the talk what we
were able to do is using Churchill we
were able to perform genomic analysis of
an entire population of 2504 so on pause
this was about 148,000 input vials
around 68 terabytes of compressed data
tolling eighty five trillion nucleotides
we did this analysis using a haplotype
of where genotype ER and we're able to
perform joints uncle calling and the
final result was closely correlated
without a thousand genomes group they
were able to do all this in seven days
so I just want to end this part of the
talk by thanking the members of my team
and I here at Nationwide Children's
especially been Kelly who's one of the
lead developers on League on Churchill
and James fetch it was the lead
developer / lapels and genome study and
this work has been supported there for
our partners at genome next along with
amazon web services and in Intel for
funding the thousand genomes study and
so that I'm going to head over to James
and James harness is CEO of genome next
and he's going to describe how we
actually did this from the cloud
computing perspective thank you Peter
this is a jay thomas with genome next
and i'm happy to be here to present the
genome next platform and how we
supported Nationwide Children's Hospital
on the intel i had an intel project i
had in a cloud challenge so i would like
to say that as we go to the presentation
please feel free to there's a Q&A
section at the end we're trying to vote
about 10 minutes of time
so if you do have any questions please
feel free to post those in the Q&A so in
terms of the genome next mission genome
next was formed as a bioinformatics
company to to accelerate the promise and
the capabilities of precision medicine
and it's got scientific discovery as
part of that mission we look at the
business problem that is currently
prohibiting users from doing genomic
analysis and a lot of that has to do
with the automation and the ability to
simplify the overall workflows for the
secondary and tertiary analysis so part
of our mission is to automate that from
beginning to end from the sequencer all
the way through varying calling to the
indication additionally one of the
challenges that we have seen with
organizations is the ability to scale on
the technology on the side for the for
the infrastructure and so one of the
things that genome Nexus solving is the
ability to use cloud computing
environments to remove the limitations
at a local level in terms of storage and
complete and for that we're actually
working in partnership with Intel and
Amazon Web Services and we use the
Amazon compute compute cloud to build a
software as a service that performs our
genomic analysis so to look at the
overall platform so we built the
software as a service on top of the
Amazon environment and that software the
service is layered into multiple aspects
ones we have a portal user interface we
handle the authentication the content
management the automation of the cloud
infrastructure as well as all of the
analysis pipelines that get are used in
terms for the
genomic analysis process additionally
the bottom layer is we deployed a
security operation center to maintain
the logging web application firewalls
and the overall compliance protection of
the environment so from a security and
compliance perspective we spent a lot of
time ensuring that HIPAA compliant on
amazon's cloud that we also were able to
work with cap and CLIA processes to
incorporate those within organizations
additionally data upload to the cloud is
something that we've incorporated into
the environment this simplified the
large data upload and we'll talk a
little bit more about that as we move
forward in terms of content management
we built a light content management that
allows for teams projects samples and
analysis crust to be to be managed at a
enterprise level we additionally
employee security trimming so that only
certain users had access the paint on
your organizational needs the cloud
infrastructure management which is
probably the thinnest would pertain with
rose to what's novel about genome next
is the ability to launch and manage
on-demand thousands of Amazon instances
of servers as well as the amount of
storage and the automation that brings
all those things together so we are able
to manage that and provide that as an
elastic on demand service and then we
have taken the Churchill pipeline and we
have been able to take that pipeline and
fully automate it onto the platform so a
user can upload data requests an
analysis submit the analysis and for
whole-genome within a couple hours that
analysis results come back to that user
so the Intel head in the clouds
challenge Peter summarized it very well
but essentially we were looking at 2500
for individuals across 20
populations obviously we're talking
about a lot of data 70 terabytes and
fast queue data and lots of fast few
files and in the end we were looking at
managing and running close to a thousand
ec2 instances over a seven day period
and being able to manage that complex
workflow from taking fast cue files
trading samples and running analysis
requests and managing the infrastructure
is really the problem for big large data
problem that we were solving on Amazon
so the first challenge is really a
challenge of data upload so how are you
going to get 70 terabytes of data from
one location to our cloud environment
and how you going to do that efficiently
and in that it's not going to take a lot
of time so one of the advantages that we
had is that our cloud infrastructure our
software as a service runs on Amazon is
co-located in the same region as the
storage of the phase three data and that
is in the US east coast or the East
region and so deploying genome next in
the same region near the data set
allowed us to be able to reduce our
latency and the time that would take to
move that large data set across and that
phase three data is hosted by amazon and
it's open to the public and therefore it
allowed us to automate the data upload
from their s3 storage to pull those fast
cue files and automate the the creation
of the samples and then eventually to
migrate the sample data to our ec2
instances to do the analysis and drop
the data back to do that we had to make
sure that we were running enhanced
networking performance 10 gigabit per
second on the different ec2 instances
that we were running
so this gives you a little bit of a view
from a user interface of the data upload
solution so there's options where you
can create samples you can upload data
we have a uploader that can upload one
sample at a time however that wasn't
going to be sufficient for this project
so what we developed for this project
was the ability to upload an index files
that map to the s3 bucket location where
the phase 3 data existed in doing so we
could upload the index and that index
had over mappings to the data and and
when we did that we were able to
automate the creation of the samples
that were used for the for the project
so the second challenge is really around
scale so the question here is we
essentially are working with 5008
genomic samples how are you going to
efficiently scale up your infrastructure
and move the data across and launch
thousands of instances in order to run
analysis you have to do that efficiently
you need to taking security into account
you also need to take an account the all
the different processes and monitoring
that has to happen so from a very high
overview of what we were working at is
on the left you will see the s3 bucket
or the phase the phase 3 data existed
within the genome next platform cloud we
were able to consume all the data out of
that s3 bucket from there we then
launched our infrastructure which houses
our analysis platform which is Churchill
Churchill we then crunch through the
data and through the end launch of
provision all the ec2 instances
necessary and then when we
infrastructure or the instances had
finished the analysis and terminate the
environment and we will drop the data
into
gene or neck secure s3 bucket and then
present that data back to the to the end
user so to go into a little bit more
detail into the environment from the
less left we have a we use at Amazon
load balancer which is called elastic
load balancing so a user would be able
to access the load balancer which then
hits the the genome next portal
interface from there we have numerous
instances running that habit handle our
web front end as well as our data based
here and I would like to note that the
architecture that we're using Amazon is
a very decouple than open architecture
and that different pieces of this
architecture can quickly be swapped out
as new enhancements to our platform
progress so once the data is uploaded to
the genome next platform by the end user
and an analysis request is submitted we
actually send the request to Amazon's Q
service and the Q services basically is
a container of many messages in our
cases we had 5008 messages that was sent
to the queue that Q message that Q is
being listened on by our church or node
and Churchill node is looking for
messages reads the message and within
that message we have numerous amounts of
information that's a no one is worthy
asked where the data is located in s3
what type of analysis is this is this a
whole genome analysis is this an exome
analysis and from that information
that's provided to the listener the
listener then launches the appropriate
Amazon machine image which contains our
Churchill pipeline and at that point the
Churchill pipeline takes over it
launches all the Amazon ec2 instances
necessary and it goes through the
analysis as it's going through its
analysis and the pipeline the the
Churchill instances communicate back to
the queue service that it's basically
our update q and
update you send messages back to the
genome that's portal that says okay
we're a duplication or at this step in
the process finally when the analysis is
completed we then are able to terminate
the infrastructure and then send a
message to the queue that says that the
analysis has been completed and then we
also send a the data that's the results
data their variant call file to the s3
bucket where it is then stored the user
once he gets the update from the queue
also receives an email saying of them
that the analysis has been completed
could then go back into the user
interface then see the result files and
download them directly from s3 so that
from you know from a very high level
overview is the process that we employed
within Amazon that was allowed allowed
us to essentially upload an index file
of all of the vast cue files in the 55
thousand and eight samples once we
uploaded it or the process took over and
all these different pieces of the
architecture automated the analysis as
well as the automation with the ec2
infrastructure on the cloud so
essentially per day we were running some
of around five hundred to a thousand
instances to get through and perform the
analysis part of the reason we didn't go
more than a thousand instances was we
wanted to maintain some control over the
environment and if there were any
failures that we weren't felling on
thousands of instances and that we were
able to monitor that closely in the
future we will have the ability to
launch more than a thousand instances
and actually do larger scale population
but for this project the challenge that
we were going through was can we do it
in seven days and so we looked at an
appropriate amount of instances to be
able to accomplish that
in terms of our cloud monitoring so one
of the challenges that we had is we
needed to make sure that we knew how
much infrastructure was being launched
at any given point in time and that we
put a capacity a cap at that
infrastructure so that when the
infrastructure hit the thousand
instances that we were able to slow down
the queue and wait until new instances
came back up so that we could use that
pole all right so in order to do that we
built a cloud monitoring solution that
was able to look across the different
amazon availability regions that we were
deploying instances check the status of
the instance and when an instance was
terminated that that became an available
instance that would then we launched the
queue and we launched ec2 instances to
perform analysis from from the UI we
basically have a very simple user
interface so once the analysis has been
submitted essentially we have looks like
tiles of the different analysis requests
and it gives you a status of what the
name of the analysis was how many fast
cubes were associated to it and what the
progress of each analysis was and we can
easily come in and check the status and
and check to see if there was any issues
for nominating the instances during the
process additionally when you go into
the analysis and review the sample we
provide lots of information around what
the sample was is it a whole genome a
whole exome we provide information about
who ran the sample additionally were
able to determine run times of each
sample as and we audit the samples to
determine how long each step in the
process would take and we were able to
do that and track that through time
additionally
on the top right once the sample had
finished its analysis and provide the
variant call file results or a user can
then download and view the information
additionally we went back to the actual
sample data so if you wanted to go in
and look through the Basking files you
were able to do that as well so that
really ends the presentation on my side
for the cloud computing environment and
different aspects are the platform so
with that I'm going to go ahead and hand
over control to Peter I know that we
have some looks like we got some Q&A
that's coming in ah Peter do you want to
go ahead and take control I'm going to
go ahead and head
okay you can then if you have any
questions please feel free to go ahead
and submit them through the QA box and
what try to answer as many of your
questions as we can I'm just going to
look at see what's coming in so we have
a question from Linda she's asking you
were able to complete the calculations
in seven days tell us more on how this
impacts the clinical and patient
experience and tell us what's next yes
one of the things that we've observed
from in terms of using these using the
results from the thousand genomes
analysis is the when we sequence
occasion we use the thousand genomes
frequencies as a way of filtering out
what's common common genetic variant is
a rare potentially pathogenic variant
and one of the advantages of using the
data that we've generated with Churchill
was that we could then go back and apply
look if they're varun hadn't been called
by the thousand genomes consortium we
were observing that some of the variants
we were actually we were actually able
to call a fairly high frequency I
believe this is a really in effect of a
doing an apples-to-apples comparison
that when you're filtering your data
ideally you want to use data that's been
the population frequency data that's
been generated with the same method that
you use to do your particular Saudi so I
think that's one way that we're going to
see this sort of impact our ability to
more accurately determine whether a
baron is common or if it's auratus our
RF is pathogenic and so we have a
another question related to clinic the
clinic from i think i'm going to
mispronounce your name so i apologize
it's a nickel oh right right sec
is asking what impact has Churchill
bioinformatics had on genome sequencing
implementation in the clinic I think for
our clinical group here the real
advantage has been they've been out a
like fully automate analysis process and
it has really removed the need for I've
matee by Malik scientists to a coming
bowl so I'm really allowing the clinical
staff in the molecular lab to run in a
run the analysis and get the results get
the results back and something that's
been one of the major advantages it's
just the complete automated automated
ottimo ization of the analysis approach
I'll save that one for James and then
have a question here actually James I
think you'd be better able to answer
this and are you able to leverage AWS
direct connect to upload data to genome
next yeah so I'll be able to answer the
from my James Finch the question is are
you able to leverage AWS direct connect
to upload data to genome next so there's
a couple of strategies around data
upload and the platform for genome next
implements three strategies one is we do
it out a solution where a user can use
the web interface upload a sample and
the vast key files associated to that
sample and in a lot of ways that that
solution works for some customers but if
you're looking to upload you know
hundreds or thousands of samples from a
backlog that's going to be more
challenging through a web interface
additionally you're going to have some
challenges around bandwidth if the web
interface if you're if it's choppy or
going to have a good bandwidth you can
have some challenges that way so the
other option that we do have is to
leverage amazon web services
direct connect as well as we can provide
isolated s3 buckets to users and give
them secure access keys for their
organization where they essentially
would be able to write directly to a
specific Amazon storage location and in
those cases we essentially allow them to
use any tool that they have any
third-party fools so there are tools out
there called like s3 browser there's
some that are that are pretty
inexpensive also there are some tools
out there are from commercial vendors
that allow for data migration to Amazon
s3 so utilizing some of those
third-party vendor tools you can quickly
upload data additionally the Amazon
Direct Connect allows you to have a
dedicated line to an Amazon termination
point so that you can have a better
performance on your bandwidth from your
facility directly into Amazon the third
aspect is really it's also an Amazon
service but we have the ability to allow
customers to upload data to drives and
we can then drop ship those drives
directly to an Amazon facility securely
and then they're able to upload the data
directly from those drives to a secure
amazon storage location that we have
access to in those cases you know if
you're if you're looking at petabytes of
data probably doing something using our
Amazon import method I just mentioned
would probably your best bet
additionally a question from Linda did
you did the calculations within seven
days what was the original target was it
considered a good result so the original
target was it was seven days the in
terms of uh was it a good result at this
point we don't know of anyone that's
been able to
analyze that amount of data and that
many genomic samples within seven days
we probably could have done it faster
but you know we wanted to make sure that
it was it more of a controlled
environment as I said moving forward
with the ability to use Amazon's on
limited compute environment and their
storage as well as a lot of the upgrades
of Intel are going to their processor
and chipsets we feel pretty confident
that we can actually get that in under
seven days and be able to launch more
instances and do Roger population scales
with that I'm going to pass the baton
back to Peter okay well thank you
everyone for listening today if you have
any additional questions you can feel
free to submit them through the
elaborate site today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing fruits
for the next six months you'll receive
an email from lab roots learning you
when it's available for replay and feel
free to forward that to any of your
colleagues who missed today's mail mr.
today's line whether them and to finally
I do want to thank our sponsor Intel for
making today's educational webcast
possible and thank you all for your
attention and goodbye